has MGM plus been promised a Stargate
series by
Amazon welcome to sidere your SciFi TV
and mov
[Music]
Channel once again I'm at work but I
have had an interesting email from one
of my sources literally coming in about
10 seconds ago that source is basically
saying that they believe over MGM plus
and the CEO of MGM plus Michael Wright
believes that Amazon have verbally
promised a series of Stargate now that
would basically be something that would
be potentially be green lit
and given priority early in the next
year so when MGM plus put out its
development model and development list
that it does each year um towards the
end of January that we might actually
get to see Stargate on that list that
development list would be for MGM Plus
in the United States and who knows
internationally but this is the first
time we've had a hint that perhaps
Amazon are actually going to follow the
5-year plan or something similar that we
reported on Sidetrack that MGM plus did
put forward to Amazon just over around 6
weeks ago this 5-year plan included
movies and television series and indeed
basically including phase one of a
Stargate plan now we have heard rumors
before that Amazon were looking to
acquire two or three sound stages
predominantly for Stargate they would
basically be the Stargate Studio space
that this studio space was probably
going to be in Canada probably near
Vancouver and the actually the Hackman
Group which is the world's largest
individual owner of studiio space was
going going to be providing this space
for Amazon but it would not be until
next summer now the theory being that
this studio space could be utilized for
both the series and the movie so this
news from MGM doesn't necessarily mean
that the movie isn't going ahead in fact
it just means that many of the rumors
we've heard previously are becoming more
likely so what do I think and where do
we stand right now with this well
obviously I can't tell you much more
about the source but what I can tell you
is that they are very close to MGM plus
and the decision makers there and if
they believe this then there must have
been some sort of meeting that has had
some sort of verbal agreement we also
know though that Michael Wright the head
of MGM plus has been fighting scrapping
for Stargate basically since Amazon took
over he believes that it is vital for
MGM plus and if MGM plus is going to
grow and and become a sustainable
platform over the next 5 to 10 years
then they need desperately shows like
Stargate and they desperately want
Amazon to support them MGM plus really
needs a Stargate series and Michael
Wright knows it so this might be the
first step towards them getting that
series they really really want don't
forget that if you're enjoying the video
and you want to help support the Channel
we need you a thumbs up on the video and
we need you to throw a comment on it
really helps with those tricky little
YouTube algorithms I actually think it
is very likely that Amazon have verbally
agreed this at the moment and perhaps
not gone as far as green light in it
just yet I think their problem that they
have currently with looking for Studio
space is probably going to delay that a
little bit longer but at the end of the
day as soon as that studio space is
available
but at the end of the day the Hackman
group are delivering more Studio space
to Amazon every day and in the next few
months they should have the capacity
they need the source has confirmed to me
as well that actually the lack of Studio
space is also affecting MGM Productions
not just Amazon so we can probably say
that that rumor has now been
confirmed let's just wait and see what
the new year brings because I now don't
think we're going to be hearing anything
proba probably until well January
February period but when MGM releases
its development list for the next year
that will be very interesting because if
Stargate is not on that then well
something's going on but guys get into
the comments tell me what you think is
this news from MGM Source interesting
does it make sense that Amazon would be
making these sorts of promises MGM plus
is desperate and has been scrapping hard
maybe Amazon had just given them a bone
to you know keep them happy or is this
actually a sign that a lot of the rumors
that we've been hearing are true and
that is all starting to very slowly come
together all been delayed thanks to the
strikes and the restruction of MGM and
so on and so on but finally we might
actually be getting some solid news soon
and that's what we most desperately want
so again to the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out you and you'll never miss any of
our new videos and you won't miss the
announcement of Stargate when it does
get official also you can go to c.co
which is our dedicated website where we
have stories based on most of our videos
and we try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest also you
can go to patreon.com if you want to
support the channel as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]